what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch a
movie because the trailer for trolls 3
is coming out and we were like there's
no other time than now to cover trolls
it's been on the list for a month we
were talking about it a while ago who's
we Roxy The Strider Roxanne how are you
you know what you have a horror story
about trolls growing up I remember
selling me this like a month ago he
ain't really sad I used to take the
trolls and I would give them haircuts as
kids would do and then the Hair Never
grew back and that's how I learned my
lesson in life she was 17 years old when
this went down I said a kid under 18 as
a kid yeah let's do this ladies and
gentlemen you know what to do leave a
like be sure to troll Roxy she doesn't
like another DreamWorks animated movie
you did like that movie didn't you but
you said some stuff that got you some
crap isn't that what happened with that
movie you really liked the person you
did he really liked it but then I
haven't seen the movie yet but I was
like I thought you really liked it no
listen I'm used to it and that's okay
I'm not gonna be everybody's favorite
immediately but I tend to grow on people
like a fungus and everybody loves fungus
that's what I love to invest in here
fungus I used to say like a leech and
then somebody stopped me once and
they're like you know what leech doesn't
grow on somebody right there they suck
off and they're feeding off of them yeah
you don't want to go with the leech let
me be your leech full-length Reaction
watch along so you sync up with your own
copy available for super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page thank you all have
joined showing your support we also got
a website for our patrons to make it
easier to navigate all of our posts
that's cool follow her at the world
girls
um they're world-girling around all the
time all day every day let's get into it
[Music]
in the happiest tree lived the happiest
creatures the world has ever known
trolls nailed it one day the trolls were
discovered by a Bergen
what is a bird you know you know didn't
know how to sing or dance or even hug
they were the most miserable creatures
in all the land ah okay they wanted some
of that happiness for themselves
monsters that's how you get happiness
you eat it
foreign once a year every year
Bergens would gather around the troll
tree to taste happiness
unbelievably dark they called
trollstis
[Music]
like Bowser's Palace
yeah yeah it's a good call
whoa
daddy wake up
wake up wake up wake up daddy
wait
[Laughter]
ing
oh one day to be happy no one day to be
happy I'll give you a hundred dollars if
you can name what they're called
trolls
the other people the Bergens I think
that's it bummer there is one amongst us
who has never tasted a troll Prince
Gristle
I remember nervous my first
Time same this kid's movie Roxy be
careful
the happiest most positive
troll of all
and they call
princess poppy ooh make me happy
princess poppy no what are you feeling
oh I am yeah
it's fake
fake I actually really like the
animation a lot 100
we'll find them
they replaced all their stuff with fake
ones those smart trolls they trolled
them no troll left behind
thank you King Pepe thank you yes
because the puddles are the problem
[Music]
s
all right
[Music]
take off your pants take it off
foreign
oh what he sacrificed himself no troll
Left Behind go get him I think he's dead
did he make it out yes or no he's no I
don't think he's dead I think he makes
it out he's gonna make it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's inappropriate can you acknowledge
that I was right you were right I'm
sorry is that why people don't like me
down here ungrateful throats I'm not
gonna lie so far so good I know that's
pretty awesome what's gonna make me
happy now
come here son
nothing
you will never
ever ever
be happy
never
ever
Savage this is already so much better
than I thought it was gonna be what were
we now
sweet acoustic acoustic
foreign
relatable music for the adults and now
every troll is free to be happy and live
in perfect Harmony
that's why we hug every hour yep every
half hour
[Laughter]
more cowbell
[Music]
whoa
yeah let's Go soundtrack
don't do that it won't grow back
I'm loving the animation yeah
awesome
why is one of the trolls a giraffe this
is borderline hypnotic for me
don't stop Won't Stop the Beat
what's happening here they're all
holding hands I was like they were like
they wanted me to give you money
is that what you think of me they went I
was like Arena high five figures giving
you something good job I could hear you
from a mile away
is that Justin Timberlake I think so you
always ruin everything warning us about
the Bergens no I don't
the Perkins are coming
the markets are coming it's like the
British are coming
picked up on the truck
[Laughter]
[Music]
smart history major you mean you're not
coming to the party tonight but it's
gonna be the biggest the craziest party
ever why does he look like that
formed
Bergen's right to us I know you have
happiness inside you you just need our
help to find it
poor guy I wouldn't be caught dead at
your party but you will be caught and
dead thanks for sharing your unique
perspective on things again Russell
Brand how
please
[Laughter]
Bible of every
rule is in your hands I sure hope the
answer is singing dancing and hugging
because that's all you know how to do
can't believe you're gonna be Queen one
day
you're such a hater
[Applause]
this movie is just one music video after
another
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
is this what it's like playing with
trolls it was not my experience no
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
yeah
great signal
trolls
why would you send that up when you know
the virgins are looking for you I hope
they're called virgins like virgin yeah
not virgins
[Music]
wow this is scary and sad
puppy Creek
wow it kind of reminds me of like those
Leica movies like Coraline thanks for
throwing the biggest the loudest the
craziest party ever
they got really inventive with how to
use the hair yeah totally and I know
firsthand it doesn't grow like that so
you messed up as a child not realistic
that's the least realistic part of this
movie
also I wish some of them had their ears
pierced you got a bedazzled one enjoy it
is it coming back
we have to find a new home mourn your
dad we have to
we have to run
long time ago I'm not the king I once
was yeah you look like you became an
addict or something
I have to at least try no you can't go
to Bergen Town by yourself
it's impossible
impossible is nothing Justin
Timberlake's gonna help out
is he not aware of the situation that
just went I don't think so it keeps all
the cards
I'm not going to your party the party
ver we just got it
attack bunker boy
why is he kidnapping her because he's a
bunker guy
art will you go to bergentown with me
and save everyone what no they're your
friend
ah they're your friends I'm staying
right here in my bunker where it's safe
yeah I really only have enough supplies
down here to last me 10 years 11 if I'm
willing to store and drink my own sweat
oh
it's great
that Justin Timberlake's the most
annoying character
he'll grow on you
told her the party and I threw it anyway
and it's my fault
the trolls they were taking why don't
you try scrapbooking them to Freedom
Savage solid burn branch
thanks anyway I think he's going to
become our favorite character yeah for
sure he's gonna have the biggest Arc
Wonder
what your bunker what
oh
it'll last them two weeks then I guess I
better hurry You Won't Last a Day out
there and you won't last a day in here
oh she is manipulative Savage please be
careful
don't worry dad
can do this
oh
what happened to her mom we need the
whole backstory
let's go
[Music]
I love this like 60s color aesthetic
yeah it's great princess poppy set off
to rescue her other friends confident
she'd make it to Bergen Town on her own
Poppy's dope Anna Kendrick has a great
voice I know I love her voice it's so
young and fresh it's just very cute you
sound like a vampire
me
so young and fresh and I can't wait to
suck
we have very similar voices
[Music]
the hairs like Venom or Spider-Man and
Venom
oh
[Laughter]
I'm not giving up today there's nothing
that is cool
[Music]
yeah
oh I'm marching along I Got Confidence
wow
I can't think that way cause I know that
I'm really really gonna be okay hey I'm
knocking oh my God it's kind of talking
about manifesting I know
[Music]
this is a modern tub thumping
tub something
it's kind of like a Mario vibe to me too
you knock knock me over you knock knock
me over
I will get back up again
wow this movie is crazy where's the dude
Justin Timberlake yeah I feel like he's
gotta come right no yeah yeah yeah
c-o-m-e
obviously bro speak sure
[Music]
thank you
yeah JT know it
um
[Music]
what the hell yeah
oh [__]
okay this is what Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania should have been I love
that movie
feels like the trolls are pretty low on
the food chain
[Music]
hahaha
right on time oh right like you knew I
was coming we did we get to the edge of
bergentown without being spotted which
will then lead us to the troll tree
right before we get caught and suffer a
miserable death at the hands of a
horrible bloodthirsty Bergen they're way
too negative men
I love scrapbooking
you don't seem to care about that I do
not care about scrapbook
it's a lost art
do you have to sing
in a good mood Hakuna Matata I was
getting Lion King Vibes earlier
they're a live Branch I know it you
don't know anything Poppy and I can't
wait to see the look on your face when
you realize the world isn't all cupcakes
and rainbows because it isn't it's so
meaty yeah
imagine everybody gets to be like pink
yellow purple whatever and you're gray I
think you might change colors by the end
of the movie you think the trolls have
ability to do that that'd be cool good
night Satin
[Music]
what's your troll name uh Grizzle that's
a good one yeah you could be rolly rolly
not bad
growly
don't
hug him you gotta go hug him hug him the
non-contential hugs are not cool man and
he did not consent what trauma did he go
there
[Music]
the mix of songs brilliant I don't sing
and I don't relax shut up Justin
Timberlake I also like a little silence
[Laughter]
[Music]
I feel like if I was in a bad mood this
would be
beer every sleeping
[Music]
[Laughter]
totally
[Music]
of Silence I'm not gonna lie guys I was
not expecting this video to work but it
is totally working wow thank gosh we
came in with the expectations that we
did this is oh
rule no honey
Buddies
instrumentals a whole wisely for one
will lead to Bergen Town and the others
to certain death who said that tiny
person caterpillar me oh hey guys how's
it going do you think you can tell us
which is the right one you bet it's
about looks of them I mean who were
socks socks with no shoes
oh
but outside it was weird
oh I know you'll do it
but will he all right dumpy diapers up
high oh that's a perverted cloud
don't be diapers make Daddy happy that's
weird come on just one little high five
oh no thanks I'm good
thank you for that demonstration really
cleared up exactly what I will not be
doing Branch it's
it's fine
can you high five yourself or is that a
clap that's a
It's just sad
[Music]
with a fist bump shark attack
jellyfish hand sandwich oh my God
what gear shift
I like monkey in a zoo I haven't used
that I've never heard of that yeah
I don't think hug
[Laughter]
come back
[Music]
[Applause]
ah we're here it looks like a cotton
ball
I'm run Bergen Town laughs
oh I let's I'm going
feelings I got sunshine
not for long the future is coming on
because they haven't been eating the
trolls you shouldn't need your happiness
to come from someone else Greg
shut up I need validation
he's not that different
[Music]
even now they're positive why are they
singing so this means
we might actually get to be happy that's
right you'll never be happy no matter we
must all remain calm a com troll is a
tasty troll
and you are a key ingredient in my
recipe for Success oh
oh she's vicious by this time tomorrow
I'll be Queen true happiness
[Laughter]
it's like we all think our happiness
comes from somewhere it doesn't It's
gotta come from within they're not
understanding that's a lesson for Justin
Timberlake as well yeah in real life
stop looking to Jessica Beale for
approval I'd probably look to her too
though it was hard off I was wondering
yeah could you try to be positive
sure they're not only alive but about to
be delivered to us on a silver platter
thank you that wasn't so hard was it
Branch look they're alive and on a
silver
Plus
that's funny [__] Roxy it's clever
it's in enough yummy heads to feed all
Bergen's house
if I were truly worried would I'd be
willing to do
[Music]
oh my God are we gonna do this no
something stops it shouldn't we wait for
trollstis every day is trolls to swim
you have trolls yeah I guess
ah
[Laughter]
I'm nervous now they're actually gonna
do it
but I think it's just
a kingdom
oh yes
this is dark do you think the trolls
slipped out somehow or something it
could poop it out like it already
slipped out of the taco
base it poppy sometimes people go into
other people's mouths and they don't
come out that's what she said
poppy Poppy's a hero an innovative
[Music]
you know man you'll give yourself enough
credit
it's a bummer that his name is branch
no poor guy
[Music]
what
she loves him
did you know this no no I did not know
this no there's been no no seeds foreign
but their happiness might be in each
other I guess I can see
[Music]
oh sexy and my arms are
aggressive whoever this is is a singer
astute observation right well like Anna
Kendrick I know she she does my favorite
last five years of Pitch Perfect like
this is like a actual here we go sounds
like that to me guys
[Music]
that was a good note though
sooner we can save Creek what hello
[Music]
is it me you're looking for hmm
how could you possibly think Creek's
still alive I don't think he's alive I
know it he's alive and that's enough
you're not smarter than the writers Roxy
I stepped on that hard
going
[Music]
no don't be mean to her what if there
was a way
troll King gristle put in his mouth I
would do anything to save him we can't
get anywhere near the king without him
eating us
how do you know he's alive he didn't
seem true you can what if he thought you
were this total babe what kind of total
babe would be dressed like a scullery
maid
I smell it gravy
if you get us Creek and we'll get you a
date with the King
wow this became a movie absolutely
different movie all of a sudden
disappear all your insecurities
just don't sing branch you don't sing in
groups
I get it that was my best yeah that was
it took me a while but it's brilliant
because he was part of NSYNC do you guys
get it yeah yeah I got you I got you
covered
okay
what
oh how did that stop the presence
I was the one singing
[Music]
no
he's The Bachelor
I was so lost in song
I didn't hear my grandma trying to warn
me
oh
wow
[Music]
forever is going to start tonight I did
not expect this to happen as silly as
this movie is I legit got chills at that
scene I'm like that's tough my grandma's
my girl that's my person Grammy stuff
moves me I had no idea
I just assumed you had a terrible voice
no no it was like an angels
at least that's what grandma used to say
oh
whoa whoa what are you doing it's not
hug time I just thought you could use
one oh that's sweet everyone
but they always said the auto two movies
[Music]
yeah you are oh
game ah
I actually thought he looked better
before
whoa
[Music]
she looks like a troll
this is like a whole other movie and I
like it
was that 90s movie the girl with the
glasses brunette yeah yeah
uh uh
she's all that I think you look fat what
PH that oh
hot lunch
total honesty from a total babe
oh your name is um lady glitter Sparkles
serious serious my name is Lady glitter
Sparkle series well Milady glitter
Sparkles seriously join me for an
evening at Captain starfunkel's roller
rink in arcade yes you'd be delighted
yes you'd be delighted yeah you would be
what
have to warm him up first do you know
anything about Romance of course
passionate about it yeah you know about
romance bro romance killed my father
[Music]
you are fantastic
compliment him back I like your back
your eyes uh ears stay are you okay
what's going on are you making fun of me
to be honest Eyes Two pools so deep I
fear
if I dive in
I might never come up for
knew it
and your smile
Sun itself turns jealous and refuses to
come out from behind the clouds what
shine half is bright yes his smile and I
do have a nice smile don't I you don't
use it yes
you do
it's not gonna pop you yo yeah God you
caught on bro true happiness is possible
what do you think now
put the troll in there I knew it because
you're gonna be there as my plus one yes
yes
that auto thing man
what did you have in mind
[Music]
Ariana
Maybe
you would know better than me I don't
know poptastic
[Music]
huh
man they really went all out here with
these trippy visuals
your majesty
[Music]
meet the lovely lady glitter sparkles
who remind me of someone
foreign
just get my worthless scullery made to
get another place setting ready for the
lovely lady I want her right by my side
hey lady glitter Sparkle lady glitter
sparkles
I'll see you at trolls this yeah
take the owl my dude oh my God
Cinderella let's go
[Laughter]
We're Gonna Save Creek and life will be
all cupcakes and rainbows again up top
too slow
wow that's hot
yeah
fresh
then how about just for tomorrow oh this
poor girl
oh she's too good of a person this is
why they shouldn't have done it man you
gotta be yourself
[Music]
good I feel good you know your guys's
voices aren't that far off that's so
rude I'm done with you
everybody hold on
hold on wowza wow
no you gotta be kidding me
[Music]
oh oh thank God
why don't you guys take him out of there
oh
Avatar
[Music]
is he not in there
oh
good I'm sorry poppy we're too late
actually our timing is perfect
oh that [__] this is what we call All
Is Lost The Darkest Night of the Soul
save the cat
I mean every Troll and troll Village
you'll never find them not where they're
hiding
hiding I could with someone they know
like this guy
he's selling us out
no I don't believe it
that's surprising I don't want to die no
don't eat me eat someone else anyone
else everyone else but not me but that's
not happened
but we saw this part
oh dude has he really turn on them this
is like a metaphor for Russell Brand's
real career
he doesn't know where the bunker is
though
that is cruel oh that's what yeah oh my
God
that is evil he is wow wow I feel like
there's some Tim Burton stuff going on
that's what I said earlier Roxy you're
just repeating my point earlier not if
you cut your point out of the video and
just in case I don't control the edit
and make you look better
oh my God everybody I love throwing in a
pot thanks for asking are you being
sarcastic
oh my God
wow welcome to the dark side sarcasm the
cowards lie the world isn't all cupcakes
and rainbows
better singular heart out I would live
for a cupcake right now
oh starting crazy right to these colors
I told you she's hardened but you guys
don't get is that she's horde
she's hard what
what is that
she's hard
are they all turning gray oh my God oh
my God you better sing your heart out
what happens when the hug watch goes off
they're all hard okay not one of you
kept the hope no she's the leader they
follow her there's one with the kind of
green nope
here it comes
all right branch
she had earrings
don't be discouraged
it's hard to take courage
you can lose sight of it all the
darkness he's a singer
hug it's hug time
oh
come on
no switch roles
what are you showing the king is waiting
get those trolls up there
keep singing it sounds like Lady Gaga
yeah
[Music]
it might be right Star is Born that's
what that those notes sounded like
whatever I can't stand you
cause I will always true
[Laughter]
I see your truth
and that's why I love you he does oh
yeah that's right lay one on her buddy
afraid
to let them show yeah
yeah yeah
good job this is good this movie's good
I don't care look at him he's blue he's
a Smurf I kind of wish she turned a
different color don't ruin it wrong okay
[Music]
I don't want to correct collect trolls
now don't cut their hair okay thank you
no thank you
yeah good how to be happy really
now
[Laughter]
this is inside of all of us right right
sometimes you just need someone to help
you find I've said that I still look for
likes and comments
it's a fake out yeah she's helping them
Sparkle Girl
showed me what it feels like to be happy
it was actually just compelled by what
was happening but thank you
didn't want to leave you hanging
no are they gonna kill off Bridget no
he's gonna fall in love with her
and find out about happiness
Bridget just ruined her life save ours
it's not right
she deserves to be happy as much as we
do they all do oh they all do
she's got to teach them a lesson that
it's not about eating trolls Greg what
did you do
you ate them you greedy greedy Pig oh my
God
[Music]
what are they gonna do
what's the plan here guys you're gonna
make her hair
[Music]
[Laughter]
when you were with Bridget you were
feeling something weren't you yeah I was
I I just thought it was too much pizza
happiness yeah
no it's a lie your government is lying
to you
here I am
my belly empty
empty and my heart full
that is what I'm talking about happy
it's inside you it's inside of all of us
and I don't think it
I know it feel it stop you are dropping
the ball homie Jesus
I'm embarrassed I'm ashamed
[Music]
sunshine in my pocket good soul in my
feet was this for this movie maybe it's
awesome
nowhere to hide
wow I bet because this is 2018 right
yeah yeah totally yeah JT wrote this for
this I'm sure somebody else wrote it but
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah that's move it feel it in
the shoulders yeah come on Let It Go
[Music]
dude look at them go
taste of your own medicine
they just set her on fire
oh my God
dance dance dance
got this feeling
[Music]
the happiest tree yeah yeah good catch
[Applause]
our new Queen
Poppy I know it's not officially hug
time yet but
now that I am queen I decree that hug
time is all the time
give it to me whatever
what's the hands yeah the cloud is up
high
[Music]
no way
that
was a surprise
here we are you don't know the situation
Roxy now we're going through before we
started this movie I spent like five
hours telling her I don't know if we
should do Point Break or trolls and I
was like well we've had trolls on the
list for a long time and they have a
trailer coming out so I feel like it'd
be a good time to do it but we were also
kind of leaning towards Point Break It
doesn't have the worst reviews of
anything I've seen but does it have bad
reviews because adults suck
I don't know
I don't know like why would this not be
annihilating
executive music producers no way Zoey
Deschanel which one was she we'll look
it up let's see if we can remember who
the characters okay you know Christine
Baranski or whatever that's probably the
the woman the evil person Gwen Stefani
Gwen Stefani interesting well look it up
okay as a matter of fact we can
multitask right now all right do your
thing I just don't understand why this
wouldn't have annihilated to me it's a
story about happiness obviously it
doesn't take a genius to follow that but
there's got all the elements it looks
cool there's friendship there's love
great voices awesome music
a short good journey oh does the
audition that was Bridget
whoa yeah who's the one who's saying and
I was like okay she's a singer oh it was
Gwen Stefani what do you mean wait was
it Bridget when I said that she sings
Yeah
that's what I said it was Bruce's number
yeah I don't remember
Bridget first saying she was singing
about being in love with the King
oh okay you remember that oh no whatever
man I remember let's see if this is
everyone shut up the creatures in this
and the World building are kind of dope
you said Timber I was talking Leica
which did like those Tim Burton animated
movies and they've worked a lot of
people worked on like they're like
ParaNorman
I said Coraline we're referencing the
same as how weird is it that Netflix is
recommending Rocky to us after trolls
uh I don't know something about my
algorithm on Netflix
suggesting that I should be watching
Rocky after watching troll they were
like oh you feeling good all right
they're trying to figure out my taste
right now they don't recommend trolls
too they're recommended so watch Rocky
there are three trolls movies uh I mean
the third one is coming out uh I don't
know this is trolls holiday trolls the
beat goes on ah dude it's like you know
you know how these animated properties
are they have like other little side
flicks there's a trolls too for sure
that's out we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to do trolls too I was very
surprised by how much I enjoyed that
movie because
um yeah I don't know there was something
even when I saw like the when you like
hover over a video on Netflix you're
like oh yeah they're playing like a
little bit of the scene like this does
not look like my taste right now but it
was kinetic funny and they had that
Peril whenever they come what were those
called the birken dots or what were they
called the burgers the
Bergens Bergen yes what do you think the
sequel is what do you mean the Bergen
dot I forgot what their names were I
added too much to it you're just talking
about the villains yeah the Americans I
think virgins would have been funnier
because we're all scared of a bunch of
birds
done
oh I'm with you uh I was really looking
forward to watching this movie
um it's opposite day I was not no I I
just haven't heard great things about it
and then we looked it up on Rotten
Tomatoes and I don't think it was doing
very well there and on IMDb and all of
that it seemed like just a middle of the
road animated movie and for me animated
is not necessarily my favorite genre not
that it's a genre but favorite uh medium
so it has to be a really great animated
movie for me to be like yes I feel like
this was a really great animated movie a
really great movie yeah yeah it was fun
and yeah I think it has some of those
like marketing gimmick things were what
I was thinking in the first like 20
minutes where you could just sort of
take you could look up almost any one of
these music numbers on YouTube it kind
of felt like sometimes they were
structuring a plot around the music
videos but yeah you did say music video
at some point I was like he's not wrong
this is like little Snippets of music
videos flash flash but when they did the
music numbers
yeah I mean a lot of it plays on
Nostalgia or familiarity but the way
they uh construct them is so beautiful
and dazzling and there are so many parts
of it that felt like I was like on
shrooms or something yeah
just like it does feel very trippy yeah
do you think kids like this oh dude it's
a huge movie for kids it's a huge
there's a reason there's a third one
coming out it's huge well I just I guess
because well it's going to be coming out
that means it's huge but the fact that
it's just not reviewed so well it maybe
it's the adults that aren't liking it I
don't think it really matters yeah I I
don't think I'm harping on that too much
because I feel like it's getting a bad
rap for no reason like I want to
actually go tell people to watch trolls
I need to start defending I kind of feel
like that even though it's a massive
film they have two bit let's look up the
box office that'll tell us if the movie
people are gonna be upset with me but I
kind of preferred this to Puss in Boots
even though I like Puss and Boots we're
doing so well so well Roxy
with a message about happiness I think
it's so lost today on finding happiness
from within and having the people around
you bring you Joy as well I just feel
like in 2023 it's all about
um romance only or about like well I I
don't know some insert other major big
themes but happiness gets lost sometimes
and this movie is a movie about Joy yeah
I thought you picked up on the very
obvious message of this movie was
surprised like way faster than I did at
the very beginning about how we look for
external things to make us happy we look
for circumstantial things it's kind of
like everyone in bergenville was a
metaphor for like Brendan Fraser's
character in the whale you know I didn't
see it well there are people who I could
definitely be that yeah there are people
who did uh I know what it's like to be
someone who often tries to find
happiness via binge eating or looking
for food or then you know there's other
ways that we can find ways to relate
whether that be you know a troll or not
uh looking for food they were looking
for food too yeah they were looking for
I'm saying that you know like but you
can you can replace food with anything
insert your your thing here it could be
social media it can be another person uh
just trying to find something instead of
finding uh self-happiness you know and I
think that is a really touching message
to have and is I thought I felt this
movie was also really self-aware of what
it was that's another thing that it
didn't feel like corny to me because it
seemed very much even the whole thing
with like singing killed my my mom and
it was a funny moment Grandma I'm sorry
I wasn't right uh no it was Mom it was
Mom I thought he's a girl it was a
grandma situation wasn't there because
you were on this whole thing about like
loving your grandma because I thought he
said they killed my grandma
usually I remember things about dead
moms because I've got one
and I remember things about dead dances
I got one of those together we have a
whole set of yeah
we're in the dead parents Cinematic
Universe
um
anyway that's fun for you guys at home
when you're watching a kids movie uh
yeah
I don't know where the parents were
during this where his mom was or her mom
was you saw her dad talk about poppy
yeah oh yeah we didn't explain that
maybe they can reproduce without having
that meat or the second one
who's made me say oh what Brent Oh you
mean it's in trolls too oh trolls 2
World Tour okay so I remember this I
just remembered the situation in trolls
through trolls 2 uh came out like Peak
pandemic when they were just and they
like we put on video demand and it ended
up being this like really huge
Successful video on demand movie oh
really yeah where a video on a man rebuy
it oh okay you know the concept of
buying it
yeah
cut me off all the psychedelics that we
just watched
I'd be really really going for it maybe
the maybe the plot is uh that lady's
back and she's like make bergenville
great again
and feeling like I hope not and she's
trying to make bring it back to the old
ways and restore it I don't think it's a
political commentary Republic of 2020 at
the time you know what I really loved
about this movie though is is the
happiness okay as somebody who is very
happy all the time no certainly not but
as somebody who believes people can
change you know there's that age-old
outage Can people really change and I
think if you're somebody who's changed
you know the answer to that is yes and I
really like in this movie that the kind
of the message at the end it's not just
the happy people who figured out a way
to be happy again it's the people who
have never felt happiness that realize
that they can feel Joy from within and
and that was the message that they that
this is it can be new and different and
sometimes things take practice and I
like that you know I that they really
experience maybe it's too deep for this
movie but when I was watching it I was
like they didn't just leave you know we
would have accepted it poppy laugh and
then we don't know what happens to this
girl but they teach everybody you know
you can wake up one day and decide I
want to improve my circumstances I want
to improve my mindset I want to I don't
want to feel like this anymore and
sometimes that takes a little bit of
practice but like it it can be for
everybody not just those in inherently
happy people that we see about that
never seem sad yeah those freaks yeah
don't understand yeah you guys are much
a weirdos no one likes you there's
nothing interesting about it I just said
something really beautiful and poignant
and I'm here to cut the tension here on
your beautiful volume Point whatever
okay did I grow on you like a fungus
I'm a really fun keep trying to keep
trying to uh redeem yourself from Puss
in Boots I'm gonna interject here
I like that movie I know
they trolled me on Puss and Boots maybe
they'll push me on troll
this stays in video yeah so
um I feel like we got to just touch on a
couple more things then we're good to go
did I take us off track no no it was
definitely me this time normally I
accuse you but this is me today who's
your favorite character my favorite
character
um of all time
oh thank you for specifying I really
okay
um she's not one of the trolls uh I I
really liked Bridget a lot Bridget was
bombed she was the one I was the most
emotionally invested in imagine being
told your entire life that in order to
have happiness you have to eat the
stroll and then deciding to save the
trolls yeah that's a religious metaphor
it's hard to put myself in religious
I'd rather not
just the religious man
oh
you told something your whole life and
then you have to use your own brain to
realize
maybe not
religion
he's about to preacher had to do thought
that she was having her
moment and you talk you commentary for
Olivia
whatever yeah I love Bridget too and I
love poppy usually my favorite character
isn't the main character but I loved
Poppy yeah yeah I love poppy a lot I
mean I like Branch as well I think the I
think they had a lot of really funny
quirky characters that were constantly I
like when movies also do this like
animation humor where it's just like
something snaps on screen basically and
it it weird [__] like that can just make
me really laugh like I love the
reoccurring thing with the it's like a
cheap joke the glitter guy who who had
the auto tune on the whole time and they
would keep it in there and sometimes
you'd have to kind of listen for it but
they would constantly have it there so I
appreciate that sound design choice and
uh yeah I even like the obvious choice
but it was a great choice I thought with
the with with the how Branch was like
grayed out and you find the color in
life you spotted that I don't know how
you did that it's because we worked
together there you it was an alley-oop
you pointed out like why is he gray and
I was like maybe because he needs to
find his color room triple dribble pass
yeah that's basketball for sure
yeah
now you yeah I agree with that I also
thought it was very funny there was a
you know from early on there was that
one line about the hugs where it's like
oh we hug every 30 minutes and then one
person's like I wish we hugged more
often and you and I both were like oh
okay this is gonna be funny yeah it was
it was fun we were so on the fence about
it on the fence we were not on that we
were off the fence we were like no I
don't know about this or like it's only
time to do it let's go that's a lesson
to us yeah no we got to open ourselves
up to happiness yeah and not live by
expectations yeah that's true and also
just to be decisive and listen to the
your heart yeah and then maybe in like
go you know SEO analytical wise it seems
like the best choice
that's why you're hurting meant seo seo
yeah yeah numbers clicks the numbers and
see what's there follow with mind and
calculation not from within that leads
to failure guys
there was one other point that I was I
keep coming in my nog and then I'm like
don't forget to make it so weird I can
Vamp while you think of it that happens
to me sometimes and then you like just
can't think of it but you know it's a
genius one is it going to be the one
that makes the whole thing
foreign
maybe it's about branch and his ark
perhaps it's about the evil girl and the
traitor troll wait I think I got it
actually that is kind of a bold choice
that they made like the spiritual guy
yeah
and then it kind of goes into your
religion
but I know what they believe yeah that's
actually not bad but there is those
people the more you front does something
it's like we get it yes yes
it was interesting to me that the movie
took an approach as they had that shift
that happens where it does become about
Bridget and the king or or the uh yeah
the king Bridget and the king and and
that um yeah the whole storyline took
place
plant the seed for this and we missed it
but at the very very beginning
um when they were focusing on the on the
Bergens at the very it sounds like a
circle like some Jewish the Persians
Meet The Virgins I like Jeff Garland
there's the Goldbergs
um so yeah they had um that at the
beginning they focused on them and they
get you kind of invested in them as
characters and and when they have the
kid being like you'll never be happy
nothing will make you happy you kind of
want them to be happy yeah yeah and I
thought it was interesting that they
started off like oh I guess
I because for the thing to have the
metaphor about the whole thing with you
know heat branches all blacked out or
gray whatever and then he turns
and then he finds colors in life and
then the movie's showing you at the very
beginning that it's not so black and
white this this story that we're about
to watch unfold it's not just Bergen's
bad Trolls good and they don't know any
better yeah they've been taught one
thing their whole life
[Music]
I'll bring 2020 politics into what I
think the sequel will be okay you bring
religion here and we bring a bunch of
enlightening deeper messages for this
movie that report are probably just like
I want to listen to That Fun Song again
totally yeah there was some fun songs
though like that uh one thing that you
and I didn't realize came from this got
some sunshine we gotta look that up
before this video that must be I feel
like that one uh Oscar
you think it won an Oscar I kind of do
what is this is called Dance
yeah Justin Timberlake Justine
Timberlake
uh is it called Dance troll song Can't
Stop the feeling oh it oh I guess it is
like a an actual
song from before yeah on you oh at least
on YouTube oh my God it is from
Dreamworks Animation can you look up if
it was nominated for an Oscar
it feels like you don't think it was oh
maybe I don't I mean oh he opened the
office he played it yeah okay that's
maybe why I'm thinking that I remember
no no you're right yeah yeah yeah it was
nominated for best original song I
remember there was something about it at
the Oscars when we started hearing it I
was like oh I kind of remember him
coming on stage with this oh that's
amazing what won against it I'm asking
you to do too much work right now okay
all right 2017 Off
2017.
original
song Oscars Oscars winner Oscars yeah
all right let's see city of style that
makes sense La La Land okay yeah you're
not going to beat that so yeah and then
you thought Lady Gaga was in this but it
was Gwen Stefani
yeah that's what happened
they'll stay in the video Yeah there'll
be people being looked it's not Lady
Gaga it's Gwen Stefani and they won't
make it to this part in the video and
I'll be like well if they didn't make it
they can go themselves you can go troll
yourself okay what's your best troll
line
wait troll me for a second
I got nothing I feel like I said some
things that offended you during the
reaction oh yeah like what I don't
remember but I was deeply offended
I'm very upset something about your
singing voice sounding like the King
singing voice my scene was dope that was
messed up of you yeah I'm sorry I'm
getting this feeling in my body uh
uh into the raspberry side what I liked
is that I said troll me and this is what
you did
I made you trailers you looked at me and
then you're like
I'm gonna look away because there's
otherwise I'll throw something
bad idea
when someone says something like that my
mind just goes for like not even a troll
I I just go like you're a dick or
something I don't even I don't even like
think of it yeah okay
you need G fuel to function uh what okay
I'll let you troll me since you're so
that's what I just did I need G fuel to
function yeah I do I work off of four
hours of sleep at night you don't even
sleep
these are just straight up facts I
wouldn't call this a troll wow you're
tired from not sleeping because you work
too hard boom it's micron
on that note people
it's Anna just go to the Puss in Boots
reaction to see how people throw Roxy on
on that one yeah and boot me here
instead
no it's not it's not my goal to redeem
you
know oh I think I've redeemed myself
like each thing yeah
wait a good call back guys leave a like
follow Roxy on the World Girls uh you
can check us on patreon uh but before we
go we gotta end this with a pig
uh oh do you know Adelia Chamberlain no
but I I don't think I know you Adelia
let me know if I do what I was just
thinking when you said that though was
that I was hoping you would pick a Delia
why
um because it reminded me of Adelia
Bedelia
what is that
I actually don't know first right now
I'm having a flashback of my childhood
Amelia Bedelia not Adelia Amelia Bedelia
was a character she was like
um she was like Judy
she was like Eloise at the Plaza Amelia
Bedelia was like this girl she went
through all these things you'd read her
books and [__]
her name is Amelia Bedelia so Adelia is
kind of like Amelia Bedelia combined
I'm gonna add on to your shout out to
Delia to make it more about you
whatever I like a deal I think you did a
great job there I appreciate your Amelia
Amelia Bedelia bro I think you did a
great job and I appreciate it I'm gonna
show you what she's like while you do
that I'm going to say Adelia I don't
know if you know this but she was one of
the people like you know how delivers
these subsections of schmodown
are you listening yeah what did I say I
know you know how there are these
subsections of the smell all right good
all right yeah I'm a woman I can
multitask I know
subsections there was like where they
were like maybe you guys I don't know
what a subsection of this I mean I mean
the fandom like yeah when there was like
other community sites and whatever and
she ran one of those and like there was
when I was ending she had one of the
sections also I probably know yeah you
probably got like interviewed by her at
some point or whatever she was one of
like the most hardcore supporters of the
shmodo oh that's awesome I'm so sorry if
I know you Adelia Amelia Bedelia is a
book this is what it looks like and
um that feels relevant she definitely
knows your personality
two readings make sure to send me a
screenshot I really appreciate that you
never got to level two nope never did
and Adelia also um is a very talented
writer that's great and scripts novels
yeah
I'm sure you've probably met her before
actually and well she you know like I'll
say this since since I first met you
through schmoe down
um
and I didn't really I wasn't a big fan
of being around Showdown to give you our
love knows uh I was a really big fan I
thought you were gonna say me so that
was so much better of a turn that could
have taken I have a really big fan of
being around I don't really talk to you
for a little while
huh
I don't think I tried to pull it out of
you sometimes but you didn't want to
answer my questions
what are you talking about yeah
the bold face lie so it's not it's a lie
I'm mansplaining your intentions so yeah
the but
um
oh yeah but and then especially with
fandom with the short on community I
just felt like for a longest time I
didn't really feel like
I belong there and Adelia was one of the
people the fandom was were you over at
fandom with me no The Showdown Phantom
oh this is the most convoluted shout out
of my life I was just trying to talk
about Delia
we cannot get focused here
[Laughter]
try to find a different angle and say
something nice
yes that was it
that's awesome Adelia yeah she was great
she makes a lot of pots sure why not
well if you haven't checked out Amelia
Bedelia please go to Amelia Bedelia
thank you Adelia
all right guys let's see I think that
was really good that was great special
the video is now concluded
[Music]